we did what was the karaoke show the
Killer Karaoke Killer Karaoke I was the
I was the voiceover I did the voice
that's right yeah it was your show and
here like so I've been doing voiceover
for 30 something years all kinds of
stuff but I got a game show Killer
Karaoke and the reviews are off the
chain they're saying it's the greatest
game show in the history of game show
and I'm going finally a Payday I'm going
to be the Bob bu Banks or whatever of
Killer Karaoke and he goes full paa the
next
year he doesn't want to scare the
Tarantulas I'm like what
what my shot man I had a
shot that is so
hilariously and true and they brought
markk McGrath and Mark no problem with
Mark but it just didn't have it didn't
have the steo magic every action has a
ripple effect that dude that is just too
much I forgot all about that there was
another time too when uh you walk away
from his show only steveo only
steveo I am not man enough I am not man
enough I would have stayed
forever um there was a time you reached
out on Twitter about something or other
I I remember we we had a little
interaction on I do remember yes I don't
remember what it was but I remember but
I think I was reacting to your T-shirt
cuz you've been fairly open and and you
guys the jackass guys I mean oh dude you
made kids her back like our second most
downloaded song I mean after used it for
the opening and it wasn't just like a
taste it was like the whole opening of
of that of that I was that the fourth
one it is the third one ja 3D ja that
made up for all the money that you lost
in Killer Karaoke the kids are back yeah
he made it right yeah I wrote all songs
so yeah so that was good that was good
Fant okay you know I get it you know
Peta whatever you got to do whatever you
he was he was just having some
realizations you were going through some
changes at that point it was uh they
they had like the the snakes that they
would dunk in the ice water with the
people while they were swimming and and
I got a lot of backlash from that it's
like dude like putting um snake
that um they weren't supposed to be in
water like it was extra cruel to put
those snakes in ice water and that was
your first Sak are cold blood that was
your first like on camera project since
getting sober right it was my first TV
gig my first ever hosting gig and wow
when you put it in that perspective I I
uh I'm torn between feeling like I've
got integrity and feeling like an
absolute idiot but uh no no you should
Integrity first man Integrity first I
mean especially for you I mean when you
decide to have integrity that's a thing
that's a that's like that's a big deal
you stand tall for something you know
sure not a shame no I just I just like
wow that didn't work out so so funny um
okay so do you know that my first
concert was Twisted Sister I do not did
not know that where did you grow up I I
grew up in London England what I'm
talking about I don't know I looked it
up today it was the the come out and
play tour of
1986 you did two nights at Hammer Smith
Odum wow and um I think I think it was a
Friday so whichever won was was a Friday
I was um playing with the skateboard and
in the backyard my dad came home from
work and he said hey what do you think
I'll take you to see Twisted Sister
tonight and I just lost my mind I
thought that was the coolest thing ever
but of course we didn't have tickets so
we bought scalper tickets at the at the
Hammer Smith odion which put us you know
maybe like 10 rows back oh who and so
like like 10 rows back from the stage
and and and my dad had me hoisted up I'm
sitting on my dad's shoulders like just
rocking out to Twisted Sister and like
one of the ushers saw this little kid I
was 11 and and I'm he's I'm on my dad's
shoulders the Usher say come on come on
let me Usher you up to the front so the
the Usher took me up to the front and
couple notable things happened um the AJ
perau threw a drumstick my dad caught
half of it this other guy next to him
caught the other half and I've never
seen my dad more physically intimidating
ever like that drumstick was going to be
mine and my dad just most it and I had
this and it said AJ perau on the
drumstick and at one point during the
concert uh like I reached up you reached
out like you slapped me a high five from
the stage for sure I see a 11-year-old
kid on his father's shoulders I'm like
cuz I'm already a dad at that point so
my kid is already four years old 5 years
old so I'm I'm totally getting like this
this that young dad with his kid
bringing him to a show so that was
deliberate it was not an accident that
that high five that slap of the hands
was was just really it was I want you to
know that that was really special man
that's awesome changed the course of his
life it was it was I mean naked Biff
naked Canadian singer um I don't still
have and I curse myself name Biff naked
and she said I Spit on her in Canada on
concert to change her life
so I said I never really spit on purpose
I wasn't like that punk thing I thought
I just like you know like Let It Go and
just hit her and she said I'm baptized
by D Snider's saliva my course my life
has been changed wow yeah so you got the
you got the good one the hand
slap now back then you had this this
whole deal you were sharpening your
front teeth I sharpened my teeth yeah
and now like the captain captain my wife
said you wanted oral fixation or oral
sex because one of them's got to
go I opted to continue having giving her
oral sex uh yeah my kids listening at
home oh listening to your show they're
all grown now you know exactly what's
going on Mom and Dad have no secrets um
yeah so I I capped those teeth yeah yeah
it it was Prett pretty you know a
vampirey yeah it was I had this crazy
idea to file my front teeth down into
fangs and um I did it and it was in
1985 so really I really wish i' had done
it earlier in my career so I would had
more time with them but by the time it
had to be 86 87 I left the band and and
um you know as it I'm already tired of
it cap them so I got these are caps
thank God and your teeth look nice well
thanks man that's why I brought you the
book between your glasses and your teeth
you look very smart do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is sto's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude